- Le taux d'inflation au Canada
a atteint son plus haut niveau
En effet, en juillet dernier,
les prix à l la consommation
ont été de 13 % supérieurs
à ceux de juillet 1980.
un taux d'inflation aussi élevé
lais p prévoir le pire.
Pour les consommateurs,
- Tout, le coût de la vieesesesz
le chauffage, le gaz pour
- Puis manger surtout! Je veux
dire, tu va faire une commande
grand chose pour 50 piastres,
je veux dire, c'est quasiment
- Les épiceries, les commerces
augmentent leurs prix comme
jamais et le coût de l'éner r rt
sombre; les gens se laissent
même aller aux pires prévisions.
- C'est-tu les riches qui
veulent avoir notre penenenenens
ce qu'on va... Pour le gaz, là,
qu'ils veulent d'ici trois ans
ou cinq ans augmenter ça
- Est-ce que vous pensez quevovt
se priver de choses dont
- J'ai bien peur que oui.
- Et pour juguler l'inflation,
eh bien, les taux d'intérêts
- La Banque du Canada a fixé
son taux d'escompte, il est
passé de 14 à 14,19 %.
du taux d'escompte : il passe
de 14,19 à 14,79 %.
- Des taux hypothécaires à 21 %,
- Il en coûte de plus en plus
cher d'acheter une maison,
de la refinancer ou de la lo
à cause des taux d'intérêts
faramineux sur les hypothèques.
- On assiste alors à
des fermetures d'entreprises,
à des mises à pied massives et
à un taux de chô
au Québec de 15,8 %.
- 1980 sera une année
de récession
provinces canadiennes.
Le Québec échappera tout juste
à cette
- Mais dans les mois
qui suivent, le Québec sera
auss
Pour les observateurs
de l'époque, la hausse des taux
la recette parfaite pour
une récession.
BOB RAE, ancien porte-parole
- L'accroissement des tauxrêrêre
à l'inflation.
- L'économis
en 1980, allait dans le même
sens.
PIERRE FORTIN, économiste
- Par dédédédédédédédédédédédéds
anti-inflationnistes, ses taux
d'intérêts élevés, ses budgets
restrictifs, crée du chômage.
qui écopent le plus de chômage
quand il monte.
- À cette époque, le taux de
chômage chez les jeunes était
le recul, constate que nous
n's s s s s s s là actuellement,
mais il y a un parallèle,
- Une différence entrehuhuhuhuh,
c'est que non seulement
de départ est beaucoup plus bast
le taux d'intérêts est beaucoup
- Nouvelle réces,,,,,,,
mais beaucoup moins sévèreéeéeé0
avec un taux
beaucoup moins élevé.iqiqiqiqiqe
Canada, n n n n n n n récession.
À preuve, les 150 000 emplois
- J'ai bon espoir que
ça va se replacer bientôt.
J'ai confiance en l'économie.
- 'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e',
ça redescend. Alors j'attends
le printemps.
- Pierre Fortin estime que les
- Ce qui est déterminant, ça va
être de savoir si la Banque du
Canada va continuer à augmenterx
d'intérêts, être capable de
décoder si le ralentissement
va continuer de faire baisser
l'inflation comme on veut.
- C'est ce que souhaitent
sans doute les consommateurs,
qui ne veulent pas revivre
la période économique difficile
du début des années 80.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.